vorrei iniziare subito con un piccolo
test
la domanda è molto semplice voi in quale
tipo di città
vorreste vivere questa città qui ad
esempio oppure questa città qui bene io
ho sempre voluto vivere nella prima sono
simona mi occupo di qualità dello spazio
urbano di mobilità sostenibile di
bellezza e vivibilità delle nostre città
sono portavoce del movimento salva i
ciclisti ho fondato dinamo la prima
velostazione che è diventato anche il
mio lavoro di tutti i giorni
sono presidente di un'associazione che
si chiama italia in saks in embassy e
sono presidente della consulta comunale
della bicicletta di bologna ma
soprattutto amo tantissimo andare in
bicicletta
questo anche insomma per mantenermi un
po visto che non so secondo figlio
c'è bisogno un po di di essere sempre in
pista
vi è mai capitato andando al lavoro la
mattina di trovarvi in questa situazione
completamente bloccati nel traffico
detestando tutte le persone che sono lì
insieme a voi in altre autovetture e
desiderare il teletrasporto
oppure vi è mai successo di aspettare
l'autobus per 20 30 minuti magari mentre
state arrivando in ritardo
all'appuntamento della vostra vita
oppure vi è mai successo di finire la
tanto agognata vacanza di agosto
bloccati tre ore in autostrada
avendo finito l'acqua avendo finito il
cibo con i bambini che iniziano ad avere
le allucinazioni
insomma avete mai desiderato di
spostarvi in modo semplice veloce
leggero e spensierato
io sì
avevo 19 anni e vero finita a vivere a
milano
volevo fare l'attrice facevo l'accademia
d'arte drammatica paolo grassi
venivo da un piccolissimo paese di 300
abitanti
nell'appennino dalle mie parti traffico
non esiste l'unica cosa che ti può
capitare come imprevisto un suo
spostamento e magari insomma grandine
oppure l'attraversamento di un cinghiale
e a milano a milano ogni spostamento
un'ordalia i tram non passano
l'auto impossibile da parcheggiare
prende il taxi
ok in 20 minuti hai speso lo stesso
budget settimanale dal supermercato
tragitti a piedi interminabili per me
era davvero difficile
la città era immensa terrificante
impossibile da comprendere
mi sentivo davvero persa dopo un anno di
questo incubo un'amica lascia la città e
mi regala la sua bicicletta
io non ero mai andato in bici in città
improvvisamente la mia vita si apre come
una mela in 20 minuti potevo essere
ovunque nello stesso tragitto che
normalmente impiegavo 30 40 50 minuti a
fare con i vari mezzi
potevo andare dappertutto nell'orario
che volevo
incredibilmente comoda incredibilmente
leggera gratuita disponibile in
qualunque orario
la città era mia la notte milanese ramia
potevo andare dove volevo la mattina ero
ritardo bastava pedalare un pochino più
veloce mentre passavo di fianco le
macchine in coda pensavo chissà dove
devono andare magari molto lontano
perché non vanno in bicicletta
pensate in italia il 60 per cento degli
spostamenti è sotto i 5 km non dovevano
andare così lontano
forse
la bicicletta è il mezzo più efficiente
che ci sia lo racconta sempre anche
steve jobs raccontando questo studio
scientifico che ha paragonato diversi
mezzi rapportati alla loro efficienza
cioè a parità di energie spese
qual è lo spostamento che questi mezzi
ci fanno fare ovviamente qual è il mezzo
più efficiente la persona in bici vedete
rispetto ai topi siamo messi molto
meglio ma anche rispetto alle automobili
e non solo è la è il mezzo più
efficiente ma è anche il mezzo più
veloce hanno fatto un sacco di
esperimenti stesso tragitto da abi sotto
i 5 km
la persona in bici arriva sempre prima
di quella in auto e il costo 5 10 20
volte in meno della più scassata delle
automobili che potete trovare sul
mercato e o una fantastica notizia per
voi tutti o quasi tutti possono usarla
e allora perché non lo fanno in
danimarca se lo sono chiesto cosa non so
cosa che cosa si sono risposti hanno
iniziato a costruire infrastrutture
hanno cambiato il design delle città
hanno creato incentivi servizi hanno
reso dannatamente costoso usare l'auto
in città i risultati il 40 per cento dei
danesi si sposta abitualmente in
bicicletta a copenaghen arriviamo al 65
per cento e in italia in italia ad
andare in bici al lavoro siamo il 4 per
cento della popolazione
quanti soldi
quanto spazio quanta salute quanto ci
costano le auto se lo stanno chiedendo
in tanti
tante città se lo stanno chiedendo
parigi madrid londra stanno eliminando
le auto diesel dai centri storici entro
2020 l'anno prossimo hanno triplicato la
rete di piste ciclabili hanno messo il
limite dei 30 chilometri orari in tutte
le aree urbane
e in italia
dice garbet nel suo libro anatomia del
potere che quando vogliamo convincere
qualcuno a fare qualcosa
abbiamo tre opzioni possiamo obbligarli
a farlo possiamo vietargli di fare altro
oppure possiamo convincerli che è la
cosa giusta
bene fantastico la nostra politica che
cosa ha fatto per convincere i cittadini
che spostarsi in bici poteva essere una
buona idea
quale di queste tre cose ha fatto
provate a dire nessuna di queste tre non
ha vietato non ha obbligato non ha
convinto hanno venduto la nostra salute
e la nostra bellezza per qualche
fabbrica di automobili che poi ha anche
chiuso ma ma noi noi attivisti noi i
puri di cuore noi seri sugli studi tieni
sui dati noi sempre attenti sempre
lucidi noi che cosa abbiamo fatto
come abbiamo provato a convincere i
nostri concittadini che spostarsi invece
era una buona idea io che cosa ha fatto
io negli ultimi dieci anni
io ha fondato associazioni o mandato
newsletter
ho fatto delle campagne su facebook
organizzato delle manifestazioni pensate
abbiamo portato 50 mila persone in
piazza a roma per chiedere strade a
misura di persone e poi abbiamo anche ci
siamo che buttati in politica abbiamo
detto il sistema va cambiato da dentro
ci siamo candidati e qualcuno è stato
pure eletto sindaci consiglieri
parlamentari abbiamo seguito tutti
questa strategia dalle piccole
associazioni alle più grandi
organizzazioni italiane coinvolgimento
per gradi dei decisori politici
lo abbiamo fatto tutti ogni tanto
dicevamo dai c approvano una legge
evviva ciclabile 50 metri
il ministro dei trasporti si è fatto
fotografare mentre va a lavorare in
bicicletta
ma perché non è cambiato niente perché
nelle nostre città a livello di smog sta
aumentando
perché muoiono decine di bambini ogni
anno investiti dalle automobili perché
non siamo capaci di fare nulla perché
abbiamo completamente fallito e insieme
a noi ciclo attivisti hanno fallito
anche quelli del consumo di suolo zero
che è entrato in tutte le regioni
baristi che regionali mentre si continua
allegramente a costruire a distruggere
le coste a fare condoni edilizi e hanno
fallito quelli dell'acqua pubblica che è
diventata lo stesso privata non siamo
stati capaci di cambiare nulla
come si fa a convincere le persone come
possiamo convincere le persone a
spostarsi in modo più sostenibile con i
dati con le prove evidenti e
scientificamente dimostrato che un fatto
non è minimamente in grado di spostare
l'opinione di una persona su un tema se
uno crede che andare in bicicletta sia
faticoso sia dentro sia noioso non sarà
certo la stabilizzata benzina di steve
jobs a fargli cambiare idea
io vi ho convinto no non cambierà nulla
da domani per voi e quindi che cosa
cambia veramente l'opinione delle
persone un esperto di marketing marco
montemagno racconta sempre questo
aneddoto nei primi anni di facebook
parlava con un dirigente d'azienda di
un'azienda sua cliente e dirigente gli
chiede montemagno lei poi ti fan su
facebook e montemagno certo io 7.000 che
all'epoca erano tantissimi dirigente di
risponde sì mia figlia di 15 anni ne ha
600 mila
ecco ecco di che ci siamo dimenticati
ecco di chi ci siamo dimenticati mentre
eravamo impegnati a fare le nostre
petizioni le nostre campagne dei giovani
cosa facevano i giovani mentre noi
eravamo impegnati nelle nostre cose da
adulti creavano nuovi canali di
comunicazione si aggregavano in enormi
community di milioni di persone si
interessavano di politica di attualità
di divulgazione scientifica o forse
pensate che di youtuber facciano
soltanto come capo videogiochi non è
così
i giovani si muovono in grandi numeri e
sono capaci di portare avanti grandi
cambiamenti
utilizzando questi canali c'è chi pensa
questo ma ne siamo sicuri 1 youtuber
italiano mediamente conosciuto può
guadagnare 1.000 2.000 e 3.000 euro al
mese soltanto dalle visualizzazioni dei
propri video poi ci sono le
sponsorizzazioni e le collaborazioni con
le aziende può vendere del merchandising
può vendere il biglietto di uno
spettacolo in cui si esibisce in cui
intrattiene il pubblico con i propri
temi sono creatori di contenuti come gli
scrittori come registi sono ragazzi in
grado di cambiare il mondo con i loro
linguaggi con le persone che li seguono
quello che funziona di questi giovani
secondo me è la loro grande libertà e la
loro grande capacità di comunicare di
usare in libertà piattaforme diverse
la libertà crea le comunità la libertà
attrae le persone crea la fiducia la
libertà è capace di aggregare intorno a
delle idee dei veri movimenti attivi
perché ci siamo stupiti così tanto del
3d sfor fusion
forse noi non conosciamo veramente che
cosa succede nel mondo
forse noi non conosciamo che cos'è ad
esempio twitch qualcuno di voi sa che
cosa twitch social di amazon ospita
soltanto contenuti in streaming
tweet è la quinta fonte di traffico dati
negli stati uniti pensate fanno 100
milioni di spettatori al mese in questo
momento ci sono 900 mila persone
collegate in contemporanea su twitter
pensatela si nn ne fa 700 mila ecco se
ci siamo così stupiti del fatto che
tanti giovani a milioni sono riversati
sulle piazze europee per chiedere
responsabilità sulle politiche
climatiche
forse abbiamo anche pensato che fosse
una moda o che fosse tutta una montatura
semplicemente magari è perché ignoriamo
la metà dei canali di comunicazione su
cui comunicano i giovani sotto i 25 anni
cosa stavamo facendo noi mentre
succedevano queste cose noi con le
nostre associazioni con le nostre forme
ci siamo aggregati soltanto i strutture
rigide incapaci di creare il nuovo
incapaci ci siamo dimenticati come fare
comunità ci siamo dimenticati come
parlare di cambiamento non siamo stati
noi stessi il cambiamento abbiamo
preteso di portare il nuovo rivolgendoci
con la nostra patetica ossessione
politica a un mondo di vecchi un mondo
di vecchi che normalmente non vuole il
cambiamento perché non può farne parte
mentre i giovani questi giovani hanno
voglia tempo energie e di cambiare
e allora cosa aspettiamo
comunichiamo con loro impariamo questi
nuovi linguaggi buttiamoci apriamo il
nostro canale twitch non dobbiamo avere
paura di sentirci ridicoli di sentirci
fuori contesto di non essere a nostro
agio
io lo voglio fare penso che sia la
strada giusta
noi non possiamo pensare di cambiare il
mondo di proiettarlo in un futuro senza
coinvolgere chi del futuro e
professionista perché ha tanto tempo
davanti a sé
noi non abbiamo saputo mettere in
discussione i nostri metodi i nostri
vecchi metodi e questo il grande
fallimento dell'amia
generazione del mio movimento e per
uscire da questo fallimento da domani
voglio iniziare questo nuovo percorso
sono sicura che fuori dal mio mondo
ci sono tantissime persone che sono
pronti a sognare con me questo
cambiamento
vi lascio con tre proposte se avete
qualcosa da dire aprite un canale
youtube
se volete cambiare il mondo
iniziate dal cambiare il vostro mondo la
terza la più semplice
domenica prendete la bicicletta andate
nel vostro parco preferito magari da
soli o con una persona che amate e
passate di un bel pomeriggio divertitevi
poi mercoledì
ricordate di quella sensazione la
mattina
prendete la bicicletta e andate al
lavoro solo una volta solo per provare
magari scoprirete davvero che cos'è la
libertà
[Applauso]